c est rien ce qu'on fait actuellement
comparé à ce qui était 100 97 98
les pillards a défendu les actions de
son gouvernement pour ralentir la
progression des dépenses en disant
qu'elle était moins importante que celle
imposée en 1997-98 par le gouvernement
péquiste de lucien bouchard
at il raison vérification faite oui en
1997-98 colère dans les rues en cette
dernière année de sa poursuite du
déficit zéro le gouvernement bouchard
comprimer les dépenses de presque 3
milliards de dollars pratiquement cet
ennemi pour cent par rapport à l'année
précédente
tous les ministères en écopait santé et
services sociaux 2% éducation 1% 2015
les manifestations se multiplient alors
que le gouvernement couillard ne réduit
pas les dépenses de l'état mais en
limitent la progression à un ennemi pour
ça celle ci augmenteront tout de même de
plus d'un milliard de dollars par contre
le budget de la santé n'augmente que
d'un peu moins d'un an et demi pour cent
et celui de l'éducation de deux dixièmes
pour sa déco est prévu qu'ils sont bien
en deux soirées taux d'inflation de 2%
prévus par le gouvernement
ici denis martin chabot réseau canada
montréal